[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this new video
of Simply learn on what is Monero so to
make you familiar with what Monero is
let me give you the example of Lena Lena
is a journalist in a surveillance heavy
country who wants to keep her financial
transactions private she's interested in
Bitcoin but knows it's not completely
Anonymous and could still be traced back
to her Bitcoin address one day Lena
comes across Monero and discovers that
Monero is designed to prioritize privacy
and security
she decides to use manureo to buy some
books from an online bookstore
she sends the payment from her Monero
wallet to the provided address which is
completely private and unreasonable the
bookstore confirms receipt of the
payment and ships of books Lena is
pleased with the privacy and security of
Monero and plans to use it for all her
future online purchases
now if we speak in short Monero is an
open source privacy oriented digital
cryptocurrency that provides users with
complete privacy and security when
making a transaction
its blockchain is OPEC which makes
transaction details and amounts
Anonymous by obscuring the addresses
used by participants Lena's story is one
just example of how Monero can be used
to protect one's Financial privacy and
Security in a world where data is
becoming more and more valuable but what
makes Monero so private if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well monero's privacy feature makes it
different from other cryptocurrencies in
order to provide privacy and anonymity
when I wrote relies on two important
Concepts still addresses and ring
signatures now still address with stilt
addresses a sender can create a unique
public address on behalf of the
recipient for each transaction with the
recipient can still receive all payments
using a single public address just like
in Bitcoin
Monero users will generate both a
private view key and a private spend key
the private view key enables them to
view all the transactions linked to the
account while the private spend key
functions similarly to a Bitcoin private
key as it authorizes payments now
talking about Ring signature ring
signatures are a cryptographic concept
that pertains to digital signatures it
allows any member of a defined group of
individuals with private keys to sign a
digital signature
in Monero when you initiate a
transaction your wallet selects a group
of keys from the blockchain and forms a
ring as a result it is impossible for an
observer to determine which key was
utilized to sign providing anonymity to
the transaction now that you know the
basics of Monero let me take you through
the process of mining Monero
Nero is compatible with various
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS Linux Android and FreeBSD unlike
other cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin
Monero mining doesn't require
specialized Hardware like Asics which
can be really expensive instead you can
use the CPU or GPU of a standard
computer to mine Monero Monero utilizes
proof of work mining as stated on the
company's website this algorithm is
crucial for securing cryptocurrencies
such as Monero by preventing issues
related to double spending that will
actually misrepresent the available
Supply now let me tell you how one can
access Monero now although many
exchanges have opted not to offer Monero
there are still places to purchase it
so if you're in the United States you
can buy Monero on track in Q coin or
binance another way to get Monero is to
purchase it directly from another person
on the decent lies peer-to-peer platform
bisc Exchange
or you can simply use Finance to do the
exchanges well this was all about what
is Monero if you found this video
interesting and informative then please
do hit the like button and do not forget
to share it with your friends also if
you have any questions regarding this
then please feel free to ask them in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you and
keep running
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here